Speaker 1: Well, I want to start today with
how Republicans are continuing to use anti-intellectual
ism and pseudo intellectual ism to divide
America and very specifically in overtly to
try to win elections.
Not in a vague sense.
They're trying to win today in Georgia by
using anti-intellectual ism to divide America
and to create this narrative of good and evil,
right and wrong, elite and working man or
whatever sort of black white framing you want
to use.
I was doing research for a story that I was
going to bring to you today, and it's a clip
of Republican Senator John Kennedy where he
talks about, oh, don't let these high IQ people
this, that and the other thing, all in a defense
of why we should or Georgians should vote
tonight in the December runoff, December six
runoff, which is which is today in Georgia
for Herschel Walker rather than Raphael Warnock.
The framing being okay.
Herschel Walker might be kind of dumb, but
don't.
Speaker 2: Let these high.
Speaker 1: IQ people tell you that they're
the ones you should be voting for or whatever
the case may be.
And in doing my research for this, I came
across a really great article that says just
about everything that needs to be said, as
well as it can be said by Jason Easley and
Sarah Jones.
And so we're going to link to the article,
but but it gives us a great jumping off point
for this discussion.
And in the article, Jason and Sarah write
How Republicans Are Using Anti-Intellectual
ISM to Divide America.
Senator John Kennedy's comments on High IQ
Stupid people show that Republicans have weaponized
anti-intellectualism to divide America.
Anti-Intellectual ism is nothing new in the
Republican Party, they write.
But Senator John Kennedy used Herschel Walker's
lack of intellect as a selling point while
urging Republicans to despise anyone with
a high IQ.
Now we're going to look at a clip.
And of course, the irony of this is, well,
you might figure out the irony, but let's
play the clip first.
Speaker 3: And these high IQ stupid people
have an answer for everything.
You know why?
Because they think they're smarter and more
virtuous than the American people.
These woke.
High IQ.
Stupid people.
Very easy to recognize.
Speaker 1: Easy to recognize this is.
There are so many subtexts here, but let's
keep playing it.
Speaker 3: They hate George Washington.
They hate Thomas Jefferson.
They hate Dr. Seuss.
And they hate Mr. Potato Head.
Speaker 1: Dr. Seuss, by the way.
Okay.
Speaker 3: They these woke high IQ stupid
people.
They walk around, they walk around with Ziploc
bags of kale that they can eat to give them
energy.
Now, if you.
Speaker 1: Want, food does provide energy
to the body.
That's true.
Speaker 3: Kale, that's up to you.
I don't eat kale.
You know why?
Because kale tastes to me like I'd rather
be fat.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Okay.
There is so much there's a lot there to comment
on, and I'm not going to comment on a lot
of it.
Notice how John Kennedy talks about how you
can tell who the high IQ stupid people are?
One of the tells, to some degree, is the way
people speak, of course, and maybe in hearing
John Kennedy speak because of his accent,
maybe he's not supposed to read like one of
those high IQ stupid people.
But we know that John Kennedy is playing a
character and part of the character is a character
developed to appeal to exactly the types of
people that vote for Republicans.
Because when you actually try to figure out,
well, who is this John Kennedy guy? John Kennedy
has a degree from Vanderbilt University and
then he has a law degree from the University
of Virginia School of Law.
And then he went to Magdalen College.
After that, I'm trying to see what exactly
degree he has.
He has from there Magdalen College.
He got a an additional degree there.
Okay.
I'm not sure exactly what he does.
He has a juris doctor that that is.
I know that we don't in the U.S. we don't
refer to lawyers as doctors in some other
countries, like in Argentina.
Lawyers are generally called doctors, just
sort of like like Dr. Jill Biden is a doctor
of education.
Doesn't matter.
He has a doctorate, a juris doctor.
He is one of those very people.
But at the same time, he has developed a character
wherein he is not one of those people.
And it's because anti-intellectualism is a
product.
It's a package that is being sold to divide
America regardless of who actually are the
so-called high IQ or low IQ people.
Now, you could argue John Kennedy doesn't
have a lot of street smarts, maybe not a lot
of common sense.
But to argue that he is dramatically different
than these high IQ people that he is criticizing
is is really just not the case.
And this is exactly how they frame these arguments.
When it's convenient, when it's convenient
to them, they say, listen, we've got brilliant
people in our party.
Ron DeSantis, who went to Harvard, I think,
if I recall correctly, Ted Cruz who went to
Harvard.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba.
When it's not convenient going to Harvard
and even getting a law degree from Harvard,
I mean, you've got it's sometimes it's great
to have a law degree from Harvard.
Sometimes it's a signal of epic never ending
wokeness and progressivism.
And Harvard is racist and going to Harvard
is bad.
It's just whatever's convenient.
And when you go to them and you actually say,
I don't I haven't heard it done, but if you
go to them and you say, hey, is having a law
degree from Harvard a good thing or a bad
thing when it comes to who should be leading
the country?
Well, you know, that depends, David.
That really depends.
It's much more complicated than that.
Oh, so then it's not really about having a
law degree from Harvard, is it?
Right now they're using all of this simply
to try to justify voting for Herschel Walker
because they don't want a Republican, Raphael
Warnock, to continue being a senator representing
the state of Georgia.
That's as simple as it is.
The topic more generally, if it's interesting
to you.
We've done so much content on it.
A few things you can check out on the YouTube
channel include the video.
Why are people falling for fake intellectual
ism?
You can also find the video on my YouTube
channel.
Why is pseudo intellectual ism so appealing?
And then lastly, and there's many more, but
of the three that I'll highlight, if you want
to see this ideology applied specifically
to something more recent like the pandemic,
the video, the disgusting, anti-intellectual
ism in the COVID 19 pandemic, you can also
just search my YouTube channel for words like
intellectual or intellectual ism, and you
will find a treasure trove of content